du kommst ins Gefängnis obwohl du keine
Straftat begangen hast das kann Dir
jederzeit passieren auch und vor allem
in Bayern denn dort wurden in den
letzten Tagen 33 klimaaktivisten der
gesperrt und das nur weil man befürchtet
hat dass sie sich wieder auf die Straße
kleben könnten aber die Polizei darf das
nennt sich präventiv Gewahrsam heißt
konkret du sitzt präventiv im Gefängnis
damit du keine Straftat begehst in
Bayern sogar bis zu zwei Monate lang in
Berlin maximal zwei Tage und in allen
anderen Bundesländern irgendwas
dazwischen so zwischen zwei und vier
Wochen ursprünglich war der lange
präventiv Gewahrsam gedacht um
mutmaßliche Terroristen festzuhalten
also Terroranschläge zu verhindern
mittlerweile sitzen aber vor allem
klimaaktivisten präventiv im Knast
findet ihr das richtig und ist es fair
dass es in jedem Bundesland anders ist